Shed extra weight safely and effectively with these tips.
You will need: exercise, water, a high-fiber, low-calorie diet, smaller portions, and breakfast.
Always consult a physician before attempting to do any exercise or diet plan.
Step one: Reduce your calorie intake.
One pound of fat contains approximately 3,500 calories.
To lose two pounds per week, you will have to burn...
...or decrease your daily calorie intake by 1,000 calories.
Step two: Exercise for 30 minutes a day to burn calories and build muscle.
The more muscle you have, the more calories you burn.
Step three: Drink plenty of cold water.
It helps increase your metabolism. Six to eight glasses a day is recommended.
Avoid drinking high-calorie, sugary beverages such as sodas,...
...juice, sports drinks, and alcoholic beverages, which contribute to weight gain.
Step four: Eat a low-calorie, low-fat diet.
Choose foods high in fiber such as fruits, vegetables, and grains to help you feel full longer.
Step five: Watch your food portions, especially with foods high in calories and fat.
When dining out, ask your server to portion half your meal...
...in a to go container so you're not tempted to overeat.
Step six: Eat breakfast.
It gives you energy, jumpstarts your metabolism,...
...and helps keep you from overeating later in the day.
Did you know?
Being overweight puts you at a higher risk of developing heart disease,...
...diabetes, and certain types of cancer.